Jeff, do you suggest creating a new email to create each new account?
If so, should payments for all those accounts be made with the credit card set up in the MCC?
Okay, so people will tell you that the best practice for with the rank and rent model is yes.
But you can ask Nick, me and some other people that that's not necessary.
I just create for me. If I'm running an MCC, I run, I set up a new account and then one campaign
under that for one website. And then I do that again, multiple times, or like on some of them,
I'm not even turning it. I just don't want them associated with my MCC. And I just have a basic
Google profile and I go in and I add account and I set it up for one website. And then I go add
account and I set up and I'm kind of running MCC, but it's just all on the right underneath the
little profile circle of yours. So it's not necessary. It doesn't mean I'm not going to get
flagged, but it's just, I don't necessarily need it right now. Yeah. I don't think there's any,
I know in Russ, I think Russ ether over in Australia, when we did a one point,
Oh, we talked a lot about that. I don't know. I don't think it's going to hurt,
but I don't think it's necessary. And so if you want to add that layer, great.
But again, I've never done that and I've never had a problem.